momento de hablar de economía en france
24 y por ello le doy la bienvenida a mi
compañero jorge hurtado jorge cómo va la
actividad económica en ucrania y medio
de la guerra bueno comenzamos con esa
noticia allí la ralentización económica
ha hecho que al menos el 5% de los
depósitos salgan de las cuentas
bancarias de las empresas en las últimas
dos semanas en ese periodo unos
1.350 millones de dólares fueron
retirados de las cuentas bancarias y se
han gastado para pagar salarios e
impuestos según las empresas el banco
central dijo que seguirá apoyando a los
bancos con préstamos de refinanciación
para evitar su insolvencia el fondo
monetario internacional dijo que su
junta ejecutiva aprobó 1400 millones de
dólares en financiamiento de emergencia
para ucrania la ayuda de emergencia de
ucrania se entrega en el marco del
instrumento de financiación rápida del
fmi que permite dar asistencia a países
con necesidades urgentes sin la
necesidad de que tengan un programa de
préstamos
concreto o que esté vigente con el
organismo y es que el petróleo también
sufrió un fuerte revés hoy cuéntenos los
precios internacionales del petróleo se
desplomaron más de un 17 por ciento esto
y los emiratos árabes unidos anunciaron
un aumento de la oferta la referencia
brent cayó más de un 17% o 22 dólares
durante una fuerte venta que dominó la
sesión hoy pero cerró en 112 dólares el
barril la referencia estadounidense
redujo 15 dólares o un 12,5 por ciento
para ubicarse en los 109 dólares en un
comunicado los emiratos árabes unidos
afirmaron que alentarán a la opep que es
la organización de países productores de
petróleo a considerar mayores niveles de
producción el mercado ha subido más de
un 30 por ciento desde que rusia invadió
ucrania el 24 de febrero incluso el
lunes llegó a máximo de 139 dólares por
barril la secretaria de energía de eeuu
jennifer granholm urgió a las petroleras
a aumentar el suministro de petróleo
según chip y morgan alrededor del 70%
del petróleo ruso transportado por marc
está luchando por encontrar compradores
rusia exporta 7 millones de barriles
diarios de crudo y combustible esto
representa alrededor del 7 por ciento
del suministro global porque es que la
guerra nuclear ya empieza a generar
reacción por el alza de los precios de
los alimentos y las primeras protestas
por ese al por esos altos precios se
comenzaron a dar en el sur de irak allí
desde hace una semana el precio de los
aceites de cocina y harina se han
disparado en los mercados mientras las
autoridades buscan hacer frente al
descontento con diversas declaraciones y
medidas más de 500 manifestantes se
concentraron en la plaza central de
nasiriyá
descontentos por el aumento de los
precios el gobierno iraquí anunció un
subsidio mensual de unos 70 dólares para
los pensionados así como los
funcionarios públicos con bajo sueldo
asimismo suspendieron los derechos de
aduanas sobre los productos alimenticios
los bienes de consumo básico y los
materiales de construcción durante al
menos dos meses el trigo por ejemplo ha
subido un 50 por ciento en las últimas
dos semanas y el maíz acaba de alcanzar
su máximo de una década rusia y ucrania
son importantes exportadores de trigo
maíz aceite de girasol y otros alimentos
para el resto del mundo algunos
analistas prevén que el descontento por
el aumento de los precios puede generar
protestas como estas en los países de
áfrica del norte y asia y ahora hablemos
de la economía de rusia y su impacto en
la economía global así es que la agencia
calificadora crediticia moody's afirmó
que la catástrofe económica así lo llamo
que sufrirá rusia por las represalias de
occidente va a ralentizar el crecimiento
del producto interno bruto global un
análisis prevé que el crecimiento
económico global se reduce al 3,4 por
ciento interanual como consecuencia de
este conflicto maurice cree que la
economía rusa se contraerá un 13,5 por
ciento este año pero si el conflicto se
alarga puede caer hasta un 24% si ocurre
una invasión completa de ucrania y esto
produce mayores sanciones las
exportaciones rusas se podrían recortar
hasta 3.5 millones de barriles de
petróleo diarios esto provocaría un
atasco en la cadena de suministro global
según la agencia en todos los escenarios
la eurozona se lleva un golpe importante
por esto rebajaron expectativa de
crecimiento el producto interno bruto
del 4% al 3,4 para este año y en el peor
de los escenarios al 1,5 por ciento para
eeuu el efecto sería moderado el
encarecimiento de las materias primas
tendría un impacto también en la cadena
y en los países emergentes orden momento
de conocer los indicadores el apetito
por el riesgo regreso a wall street que
tuvo su mejor día del año ayer a
propósito fue su peor día esto por el
retroceso del petróleo la bolsa alemana
y francesa se dispararon un 7 por ciento
tras la caída del precio del petróleo y
por la esperanza de una solución
diplomática en el conflicto entre rusia
y ucrania y en américa latina la bolsa
de brasil lideró las ganancias con un
aumento del 2,43 por ciento en su
principal índice porque gracias por la
información económica de ustedes también
muchas gracias por acompañarnos
continúen con toda nuestra programación
[Música]
a